i mean alex what do you what do you
think about the whole debate just
putting aside like how
nasty it got but just the you know the
the tech industry versus
tech because we you and i have been at
this for a while now and the coverage is
you know gotten contentious you know i
so i listened to your axios interview
because i wanted to prep for this
little show so i want to make sure that
i heard your take on this in a different
environment when i wasn't
taking part in the conversation so i
could just listen and uh
i just fundamentally don't agree with
your view of
the balance in tech media coverage and
just like just to get a feel for this i
just went to techrench.com and i read
all the headlines on the front page and
i went to the new york times technology
section
i read through all the headlines and the
times i went through a couple pages of
them
and uh you were saying you know like
eight nine out of ten are these
negative hyper negative unfair stories
and they're not
most of them are neutral a couple of
them pointed out some flaws most of them
are generically positive like if you go
read tc to pick me up my home territory
uh we're talking about yeah tech winch i
would leave out of it
um okay you know but when i look at the
new york times and i if you look at
aaron griffin or you look at
kara swisher you know and those are but
two um
you know and they have a large team of a
large team right there's probably a
dozen people
it's it's literally like seven or eight
out of ten in
my experience uh well go go read more
reporters than them i mean
if you're saying that i'm talking about
the ones who wind up on the cover and
you know
tech does deserve some things i mean
listen and nobody's more critical than
uh zuckerberg than me i think i mean
you've been on the pod with me enough
talking about that
and so you know i uh what i would just
like to see is
when you're a subject and i used to be a
journalist and do random acts of
journalism on this podcast
and you know now i'm a subject or my
companies are subjects i
the amount of times a journalist calls
me to tell me about
some horrible thing and get comment on
and i'm just like is it is there a way
like one out of four times it can
i can tell you about something moral
positive please
and the answer is no well what's funny
about this is you were talking about how
people should get off this is on the
axios podcast with the with dan primack
who i like quite a lot
um how you know people should get on the
phone and you know how much of this is
just you know on twitter i think i think
a lot of the
the contentiousness is on twitter
because i talk to vcs yeah but part of
my job you know
all the time you have to founders all
the time none of this ever comes up
and i think what we have is a couple of
voices on the vc
side who are um
looking at the looking only at a subset
of total media coverage
and they're they're conflating that with
all media
is and because they are paid to be
generalists and and thinkers
effectively it's probably vcs dose of
optimism and someone else's money
um they try to read into this and try to
extrapolate from it and they end up
looking pretty damn silly i mean
bellagi's and
ideas about how to fix journalism are
laughable um
and uh i think that it's a it's a small
fraction of vcs that are actually
engaged in this
discourse about about the media and how
it's unfair to startups because
i don't well i don't agree with them and
also no vcs that i talk to bring this up
even when we're off the record
it's only these couple of voices on
twitter and i don't agree with the the
complaints about the balance of coverage
and i just i don't see it well i mean
don't you think
that post-trump you know more
publications are picking aside
where the new york times is a little bit
more left-leaning since trump and
you know the people who pick a side
do better because people obviously will
subscribe if the
opinion page in the new york times
speaks to you a little bit more
and you know the second they publish
something from the right and listen
never voted for a republican in my life
so it's not coming from a republican
standpoint i don't know
why people think i would vote for trump
i hate him and i say that all the time
but uh you know when they fired uh the
editor of the opinion page
it just it's giving the sense that like
you know though
it's a left-leaning publication that
maybe is anti-capitalist
it feels anti-capitalist to me i can't
agree with really any of that
um i think the times has bent over
backwards to avoid calling trump racist
to avoid annoying uh the kind of bad
faith media attacks from the american
right so i'm not gonna give any play to
that i find it ridiculous
um on the uh bennett uh times editorial
page i think let's keep
the line between the editorial section
and the rest of the paper
and he was fired for incompetence not
for a particular political perspective
so i and i don't want to spend the whole
pot on this obviously yeah
it's a rabbit hole we're going to go
down but but i just want to point out
that like
you know the core element of your
critique of media is the thing that i
that i disagree with and that's where
you and i can can talk about this and
kind of in hopefully fair-minded voices
um but i will say that uh you know
it's it's never going to be mad on the
internet and uh we could all